good morning everyone
I hope you all well you're healthy we're
back with another webinar so thank you
so much for joining me today is going to
be a webinar on how to deliver a webinar
who would have fought it so a bit of a
bit of housekeeping as I want you guys
to get the most out of this be involved
firstly yet where Cameron Skinner is is
just messaged you can communicate in
there to each other or you can answer
the questions that I asked you guys I
definitely want you guys involved and
along the way as I go through this I'll
be asking you some questions
so there's firstly that then secondly
and the other tab that you'll be able to
click is Q & A and so ask your questions
here what I always do is just submit
that so in all of you should be able to
see that and click on Q&A and what
you'll be able to do is click up vote -
and on the questions that you like the
look of and you want to be answered so
um webinar inception yeah so let let
let's do this and we've got an hour but
may may be a bit shorter I'm basically
just gonna unload what I've learned over
the last four or so weeks in hope to
help all of you guys take action on a
webinar idea that you have or even if
you're thinking you know what I'd love
to the webinar then hopefully this will
give you the confidence to take action
that is what I'd love all of you to do
so first things first objectives of this
webinar we're going to do is I want to
leave all of you with practical ideas on
what you can do webinars about
from the conversations that I've been
having with people it's more it's not so
much the ideas of what the webinar on
it's more so of actually delivering one
but I've written down some some ideas
that all of you can sort of and make to
your own market and hopefully they'll
give you some ideas so secondly give you
some practical advice on the tech that
you can use that's probably the most
common question all of you guys
submitted what tech do I use do I need a
microphone what equipment do I need to
use these types of things so I will give
all of that to you in a non [ __ ] way
and just say look this is what you need
I don't want all of you to get to over
complicated with what taking in two
years because it's once you've decided
you crack on and do it
I want to give you some some just
practical tips on what I've learnt over
the last four weeks on doing quite a few
of these so tips and things that I
learned along the way and then as always
want to make it really clear on how this
can help all of you and benefit all of
you on in a sales capacity I have a
couple of clients that have started
webinars done webinars and also just a
couple of recruiters that was spoken to
the network which I've sort of pulled
this from and heard it's working and
working really well so on and give you
that as well and then plenty of time to
answer your questions so that that is
what we're gonna be doing today
so whom I as you all know Hisham Aziz
and the business that I have as these
branding is completely dedicated to
helping recruit to build their personal
brands so they can become the go-to
recruits within their niche that bad who
am I am and what I do
so before kovat 19 before coronavirus I
honestly had no intention of doing
webinars at all some of you may know
that I hosted a podcast called the
recruitment rollercoaster and I had
planned to do the the second live event
in March on March the 19th
but because obviously with everything
that went on I had to postpone that so I
was actually unsure and not if I'm
honest not really that keen to do it
online but when things started to
escalate in things obviously changes
quite quickly I was like well hang on a
minute I've got people that have already
dedicated to wanting to come to the
event I'd be stupid to not bring this
online or at least give it a go
so just to be honest of you guys doing
webinars and these types of things it
wasn't part of the a really cool
strategy it came from the circumstances
and that was the opportunity that
presented itself and I think a lot of
recruiters and businesses are taking
this opportunity everyone are is doing
webinars but who who are doing valuable
webinars to your market and your niche
not sure probably not that many so first
things first what can you do a webinar
on so feel free if you've got an idea
and you just want to sort of float it or
share or say this is what I'm thinking
pull it in the public chat box as I'm
going through this and just feel free to
drop it in there and I can talk about it
and give you my two pence but the sort
of ideas that I'm seeing I'm just gonna
I've broken it down into clients and
candidates so firstly like if you were
to host a webinar on simply an open chat
with people in your industry on how them
how they fund in the market right now
how it's impacted them what they're
doing how they're adapting like that
that is a perfectly good idea and
something that you could probably all
execute so if you were to get to hiring
managers free clients to come on in
their sort of panel setting where you
the intention and the theme and the idea
is to talk about surviving and getting
ready for the bounce back of coronavirus
in your market that is a perfectly good
idea and people will want to listen and
know what other people are thinking so
if that even if your idea is simply
we're on this webinar we're talking
about surviving the coronavirus and
getting ready for the bounce-back that's
more than a good idea and people want to
know and learn from other people's
perspectives and and how other people
thinking about it so that's a perfectly
good idea that all of you could execute
and I'm seeing quite a few people do
that I think that's a no-brainer and
then the other one because I'm having so
many conversations about it and it's
going to be a headache for a lot of
people is hiring remotely pulling
together hiring managers to discuss how
they're hiring and how they've adapted
their onboarding process and creating a
webinar in which you pull hiring
managers together to discuss and talk
about how they're adapting their hiring
process how they've done it they have
learnings blah blah blah for other
people's benefit to collaborate and
share ideas so again that's that's a
perfectly good one to talk about that
I'd be confident that most of the hiring
managers at you speed see will be having
this headache and if you could speak to
a hiring manager and say look we're
putting this on on this webinar with
we've got different leaders on there
that are going to share how they've
adapted their onboarding process how
they've on boarded at people remotely
and we're going to talk about how
they've done it how it's been different
the challenges blah blah blah that would
be valuable for a lot of people and and
that's another good idea that I think
hopefully a lot of you can action for
those of you that are on furlough if
you're on furloughs a bit of a different
game and then candidate science I think
I'm seeing a lot of recruiters do stuff
like this and I think it's a great
opportunity to deliver some real value
to candidates in your market so you
could break down maybe a series of
webinars on sort of just focus on
candidates and you could do things like
and making sure that you're ready for
the bounce back from a candidate
perspective so sort of making sure that
helping people with their series and
then an active sort of webinar on what
your CV should look like doing a bit of
a CV clinic to make sure that people are
well equipped and know exactly what they
should be spending time on right now to
make sure that they're at the the front
of the pack when there's going to be a
clearly a scramble to get new
opportunities as you start bouncing back
out of there so part of that could be
making sure your LinkedIn
profiles in check and also just having
an open conversations with candidates
and people in your market around how
they find in the market what's going on
what they're doing how they remain
motivated how they find it Michael
remotely again I think just sort of
bringing people together to talk openly
about how they're finding out what
they're doing is more than a valid idea
and something that all of you could
action and then the other sort of
candidate idea which I think could be
really cool and all of you could
definitely execute is stories of
starting remotely and working from home
so if you could put together a panel of
people that have worked from home for a
good period of time then why can't you
bring those people together and the sort
of theme is remaining motivated by
working whilst working from home and you
just have a real open honest
conversation with people around how
they've done it for X amount of years
what what have you done to ensure that
you sort of remain productive and these
lots of things just to share and advice
again on on things that we know
candidates are going to be struggling
with right now and and they're going to
be thinking about so they're there the
ideas that I sort of jotted down that
I'm seeing that I'm speaking to people
about and also let's not forget guys
that you have direct access to your
target market pick up if you're not sure
of what to do a webinar on but you want
to do one pick up the phone and ask your
clients and candidates simple as that
pick up the phone and say look we want
to really sort of play our partner in
this period we've we've got we wanted to
try and deliver some value to the market
we're thinking about doing a webinar
what would you find really useful for me
to do a webinar on oh you know what he
shouldn't be great if you could do some
stuff around hiring remotely or
preparing for video interviews whatever
it may be if you're not sure ask your
clients and candidates okay
and as
said if you if you have them if you have
an idea that you just want to put in the
pop in the chat let me know and I'll
give you my two pens if you want to pop
it in there and I'll do that okay so
next one so you have the idea what tech
do I use this is the the worry so first
and foremost like I would start with a
piece of software that is not gonna cost
you an arm and a leg and is gonna
prevent you from starting and getting
your first webinar bits in so the the
most easiest option to go for and the
most reliable will be zoom 100% so in
terms of how much is gonna cost you you
need it you're gonna need a pro license
that cost 1199 and you can then add a
webinar add-on that's 32 pound a month
so if you really wanted to you could add
the webinar add-on to zoom in the first
month do your first one in that month
and then cancel it like the zoom the
zoom option is what you should go for
definitely that and that webinar will
give you up to a hundred seats as well
and then if you're further down the line
and I 100% advice would be to start with
zoom because its most cost effective
easiest to do you might be sort of
familiar with it because you've been
doing video calls on there whatever I
would start with zoom and then if you've
done one or two and you want to sort of
level up the game a bit it's got some
quite good traction you've managed to
get you've more than hundred people
signed up or whatever I would then look
up potentially investing in something
that's got a bit more marketing
capability you can do a bit more cool
staff and that's when you could look to
spend a bit more money on it but hundred
percent you zoom definitely and then
what you could look at so what we're on
now and what I'm using is called big
marker so I pay one hundred forty quid a
month that I can cancel at any time
which I'll probably do as we start
bouncing back out of this depending on
how many webinars I want to do we'll see
but I can counsel that any at any period
or you can and the other one I'd
recommend which
I looked at was a piece of software
called webinarjam which you can only pay
for the year which is 562 quid so I
didn't want to pay for the full year and
so I won't move big marker but honestly
guys the tech confusion just use him and
the video that I watched to help me
decide this I'm gonna put in here now
though should be okay cool you can click
that so that that youtube link that I
just sent in the public in the public
chat click that have the tab open and
watch it if you if you want to just
leave EI t' this sort of confusion on
the tech piece watch that video because
i did that one weekend and I just
decided what I was going to do but
there's this chap that does a 20 minute
interview a 20 minute review on webinar
software and he'll give you his
recommend recommendations and then you
can just watch that and then just make a
decision started that is what I would do
QA is zoomed just a monthly subscription
that you can cancel anytime yeah Chris
yeah it is so that that would be my best
advice but if you if you want to know a
bit more and get a bit more context of
what I've said just click on that
youtube link watch it later ok but ok
sorry and then the other part what you
could also do which is an option is you
zoom and the vent Brian so you if you've
been attending webinars you might have
experienced this so one of the down one
of the downfalls of zoom is in terms of
the webinar piece is that this sort of
landing page that you can create with
webinar isn't that great
it just doesn't look that great doesn't
look sexy it just it doesn't look like a
that appealing at all and that's one of
the sort of advantages of using and
paying more for something like this
because you can create landing pages
really easy you can make it on brand and
stuff like that but that's why I quite a
few people use Eventbrite if you haven't
use Eventbrite honestly I it's such a
great tool and obviously I started using
it with the the podcast live events it's
great
so with Eventbrite you can create just a
bit more user friendly and nice sort of
pages where people can sign up to your
webinar so you can that's free as well
so you can use zoom and Eventbrite if
you really wanted to and then all you
would simply do is you'd also create
you'd get the all the emails from the
registrations and you'd then also email
them with the zoom link in the details
it's the the Eventbrite was essentially
um act as your landing page for the
webinar so even just using or
potentially zoom and Eventbrite that's a
good mix
and then the other thing is what
microphone do you do you need to buy a
microphone officer I'm using a
microphone right now but the only reason
why I had one and brought one is because
I host the podcast so I wanted this in
case I ever did remote interviews and
this is a really simple USB microphone
so this microphone I'm using it's called
a blue Yeti microphone and it cost
hundreds of 110 quid
you don't need to buy something like
this you really don't honestly if you
were to just use headphones like this or
I've got on now or just the Apple
headphones that you can use and plug
into your laptop or just air pods or
just headphones that will be more than
suffice that will be fine I think what
what I always try and prevent people
from just using is just speaking to the
laptop and just having a lot like just
speaking directly the laptop I've always
found that that that's where the quality
can sometimes be a bit of an issue but
it can also be okay so in terms of a
microphone and do you need to buy
anything no like I'm sure I'm confident
that a lot of you will have headphones
in the house but that is more than good
enough I think why that's more than good
enough is because if you're not just
speaking into your laptop microphone
you're you then haven't got like
people's voices and sound coming out of
the laptop like out the actual sound and
the speakers and then you're speaking to
it that's where it can just get a bit
messy so yeah don't feel like need to
buy some fancy microphone you don't and
when you're then communicating if you're
doing a webinar with other people I'm
gonna go on to sort of how you can
approach it but if you're just as I'm
talking about this if you're doing a
webinar where you have other people on
the webinar what I always say to them is
look what what I'd really appreciate is
if you could and in terms of like tech
what I need him to do is I'll just say
to them I need you to be in a quiet room
and if you have headphones that would be
my preference for you to use rather than
just obviously speaking directly into
the laptop microphone it's not the end
of the world
if you do but I'd really appreciate it
if you came to the webinar or attended
the webinar
with headphones and that is more than
good enough and that's what I've done
every time and it's been fine that's my
advice on on the the tech piece guys if
there's anything else you're not sure of
then shoot me a message but honestly
don't overcomplicate it like just don't
light for me
pick one zoom take action do it and
learn it's as simple as that don't
overcomplicate the tech the tech piece
that whatever tech is gonna be capable
of doing what you need it to do what you
need to just focus on is doing it taking
action during your first webinar and
then learning as to how you can do it
better next time that that's just the
final point on that mm-hmm so top sort
of practical tips and advice on actually
delivering a webinar are as follows and
I'll send the I'll send the I'll send
the slides after by the way and actually
what I might do
oh I didn't include it sorry okay oh
I've sent those after yeah so um these
are the these are the main tips that I
would give all of you from sort of my
learnings are don't don't make it
reliant on you to come up with all the
questions on the webinar so for me my
personal preference and sort of for me
what I would do if I was in your shoes
as a recruiter is I would do and host a
webinar where it wasn't just you like
what this is now I would opt and go for
a webinar in which there's a panel and
the reason for that is because you want
you want to be able to get your target
audience clients and candidates on this
webinar and involved so for me I would
opt for a webinar in which you get other
people involved they're on the panel or
whatnot and my go-to advice would be
don't make it so reliant where it's like
balance you to ask all the questions and
what I mean by that is pretty much the
second point which is like as part of
the registration which you can do really
easy to make a required field which all
of you did for me and I've done for all
of my webinars and it's been so so so
useful is make sure that when people
sign up they have to submit a question
and it could be as simple as watching a
question for the panel and what that
means is is when you obviously you'll be
able to download all the all the
registrations and the attendee
information you'll then have a field
which is full of questions so what I do
and what I did for this and the other
webinars that I've done and what you'll
be able to do which is really useful is
when you prepare for this webinar you
look at all the questions that people
submitted and there will be some people
that may put n/a or not submit but I'd
say 75% of people will submit a question
look through the questions and then
prepare for it and look at the most
common ones the ones that have come up
the most and then basically have them
have them on your phone on here I use
Evernote or something like that just run
them somewhere where you can see them
easily and what you can then do is just
reference a question and ask it whenever
you're sort of feeling the the
conversations going a bit stale or
whatever hit them with an audience
question right and obviously it's going
to be interactive and there's going to
be live Q&A opportunities but that is
what I would do and that's really helped
and that's men that I'm not stressing
I'm really relying on I need I need some
common good questions and I want to make
sure that I ask the questions they want
me to say that's my real practical go to
advice on that one and and then this
ties into the next part like for me a
good webinar is I want all of you guys
to feel involved and like in my opinion
I think that's what the great things are
with webinars like instead of just me
which I'm also doing a lot of now like
me just talking to you guys but if I was
hosting the webinar there's a panel and
stuff like that I would want everyone
attending to make it feel like they're
really involved and you for me that I
think that's a better webinar experience
so another tip that I've sort of been
doing recently which I know it's gone
down well I've got messages and stuff is
like when you then ask these questions
quote people's name like people like
like that's that's a cool thing to do
right so I could go right now Glenn
salvan yeah great great point there or
I've got this great question from s Khan
and he said this like like put people on
the pedestal and say great question from
such-and-such this is what their
question was like made
the audience involved and I think that's
really important and just to skip to the
final point just to add to that is be
human and make sure you communicate to
how people can join in so you notice at
the beginning of this I sort of just did
a bit of housekeeping and said this is
how you can get involved this is what
you need to do blah blah blah just
always open your webinar like that and
if you want people to interact a really
good tip that I've noticed that works
really well and I got this from learning
I attended a webinar on similar on sort
of key things you can do on Zoom to get
people engaged on training sessions and
stuff is the first thing that you should
get your audience to do is interact so
for example when all of you came in the
room I could have gone hey guys look
really exciting to have you all here
just this is the Hat these are the this
is how you can engage these they're sort
of house rules this is how you can use
this platform and let's just to kick
that off all of it be great if all of
you right now could use the chat pane or
use the Q&A use the chat pane to your
name pane and say and I'd love to know
where all of you guys are right now
where are you tuning in from where you
listening from and that gets people
using it straight out the gate so that
gives you more of a chance for people to
get involved if within the first five
minutes they've used it and they've
interacted that's another really good
good tip and piece of advice as well and
then what I've come to realize is well
from from Ireland and the final point
here guys is definitely give yourself
enough time to promote it I mean within
four weeks I did like two a week and I
and I was like [ __ ] out it's getting
hard to promote now it's a it does take
quite a bit of work so what I'm gonna be
doing now is either one one a week or
one every two weeks so you have enough
of a runway to promote it because I'm
gonna go into it in a second is you do
have to be proactive you do have to pick
up the phone and say we've seen the
webinar that I'm doing you do have to
send messages so that does take time as
well as just the marketing of it so give
yourself enough of a runway to give you
enough time to promote it and is the
final point there so they're there
that's my sort of advice and on that
so how how can sort of webinars help you
right now in terms of a sort of sales
recruit a capacity for me the main one
is Business Development massively this
is a big one that I talk about in terms
of why I think it's a great opportunity
to start a podcast as well but I think
for me from the conversations that I've
been having anyway with with my clients
and recruiters is that obviously in
terms of so Gary I'm going to go into
that in a second and that factor that
question I will answer that and so in
terms of the BD strategy and why this
can help an impact business development
is I feel like this sort of point where
we are with all of this stuff going on
and where we are with it it's yeah in
the timeline is like if you're doing
business development right now I'd
probably like to I'd like to think that
you've probably had quite a few sort of
check-in and catch up calls right now
where you've sort of it's not it's been
business development but you're sort of
calling people again hey I just wanted
to give you a call checking in how you
find the things what's going on your own
blah blah blah blah and that's obviously
business development and you're calling
people but obviously once you've done
that a couple of times there's only so
much you could do of that so in terms of
the webinar and how it can really help
on the business development standpoint
it can really equip you with a brand new
thing to talk about that will be useful
and people want to listen to so for me
how the webinar piece can help is if
you're literally getting on the phone to
existing or target clients saying hey
which one's give you a quick call I
haven't spoken to loads of people like
you that are having these similar
challenges or headaches blah blah blah
we've actually decided to host a webinar
we're going to be talking about this
this and this how open would you or any
of your team be being attending a
webinar like this I guarantee you that's
gonna get quite a few yeses and it'll go
down well so for me the webinar piece is
it will be a great and business
development tool okay so wait sorry guys
I'm just looking at the mockers answered
so Liz you just submitted a question but
not in initial can make up I want to ok
cool right so let me just answer some
questions here
actually sorry sorry to describe
back-and-forth let me just finalize this
final point and then that and then the
final bit that I've spoken to my clients
who have done webinars this is what
their family effective as well obviously
I've got some interesting data on how
many people we expect to attend and
register and stuff like that huh but
when people attend sorry when people
register obviously they're gonna have to
hand over their email so that also gives
you a really unique opportunity to
follow up as well on the phone and reach
out to people hey Gary I just wanted to
give you a call and hopefully get some
feedback on the webinar how did you find
it any topics you'd love to discuss
further blah blah blah and that's gonna
be a great opportunity to sort of say
look do you know what we do at X Agency
so there's so there's two there's two
parts of the the BD piece it's the the
before you can be really proactive and
call people and say look I'm not gonna
talk calling you about job blah blah
blah and switch about a webinar and you
should find it useful to the follow-up
calling people after and saying how did
you find there did you enjoy it any
feedback any topics that you'd love me
to cover in the future and also then if
there's an opportunity and you want to
use it as an opportunity to go hey buy
the wage and what we do here are our
agency and what we're doing blah blah
blah right it naturally goes into these
types of conversations there that's the
beedi opportunity in the sales part I
think right let me answer some questions
guys yeah some are Thomas I will be
sending it out as a recording and you'll
get the the slide deck so little is
never Liz good good to see as always
appreciate your support so he sure I'm
hosting a webinar next week freeze iam
with a cap on 25 attendees its with a
key speak on cybersecurity was
specifically theirs in education I was
planning on sending them there's the
link to zoom but not all initial
attendees can make it I wanted to open
up to Canada it's outside of education
to make up numbers and once create a
landing page as you said would it be
affected to advertise it on LinkedIn and
put the zoom link in the comments and
state there are limited spaces yeah that
seems like a good plan so I'm assuming
Liz that you haven't hurt you're just
using zoom like so you're inviting 25
people to you zoom link you're gonna
turn off people's cameras or mute
everyone and just do it on that rather
than purchasing the webinar
functionality lives in so I'm assuming
that's why you're doing that so I mean
if you if you haven't got the webinar
functionality and you haven't paid for
that on zoom then the landing page might
just be more of a headache than it's
worth but what you could do is use
Eventbrite you could do that but it
seems like you're a bit further down the
line so I probably wouldn't do that so
what I would do is yeah put put a post
out there and say there are limited
spaces that's a good thing to say of
create a bit of urgency and say if you
want to join then and drop drop a
message below with a comment yes and
I'll send you a link I think that's what
you're better off doing so that would be
my advice to that Lee see how that goes
and then maybe look at buying the
webinar functionality so then you just
have a bit more and better features on
the zoom to do QA to create a landing
page that will probably be useful to do
polls that might be useful to do that
but do that first one that's great you
take an action and then do that Gary
Howard how are you promoting how do you
choose the target market I've got I've
got a couple of slides on the how to
promote it so I will leave that for just
now but the the target market Gary for
me it's got to be a client's or
candidates it's as simple as that
obviously we want this to be we want
this to be useful and to add value to
people that you want to be building
relationship relationships over the end
of the day so for me it's gotta be
Krantz for candidates if you want the
webinar to help you to speak to more
clients right now
then make it focus on clients and hiring
managers if you want it if you want the
opportunity to speak to more candidates
right now then then flip it obviously it
could be it could be useful for both and
it would likely be useful for both in
your market but choose your target
market if your client and candidate for
me it's as simple as that
okay Liz perfect I'm glad I'm glad that
helped okay cool so the follow-up so
you've got the before for BD and the
follow-up
yeah so I think that all I wanted to say
is like let's not forget like for me
right now what's going on the decisions
you're making what you're doing it will
be remembered and hosting a webinar
giving value to your industry right now
will definitely help you be remembered
so I think that's why webinars and a lot
of people are doing them I think it's a
great option and they're also they are
actually also quite fun guys I was
really nervous for the first couple but
once you do one or two like they are
really fun so I think what I also wanted
what I also wanted to say and make clear
is you might get caught up on are how
many people like how many people are
going to attend that I'm not gonna even
get that many people but honestly um
let's not forget that the people that
register the people that attend they're
just numbers on screens like I can see
some of your names now it's just a name
on the screen but like do not forget
that these people that attend engage
register whatever they're they're real
human beings so all of you will know and
understand how valuable it is to have
ten twelve eight thirty forty people of
your target audience in the same room
like that's how you should visualize it
basically you hosting a webinar is
basically hosting an event where you get
to grab the attention of your target
audience your clients and candidates for
a period of time and that's super
valuable and really useful to do so
don't don't forget that it's definitely
to help you be remembered as we start
and coming out at the back of this so
promoting a webinar tips Gary hopefully
this will help to your point getting
people to attend so all I will say guys
is it definitely needs to be proactive
and with your marketing so do not expect
this is what I've definitely realized do
not expect to host a webinar
and everyone to flock there like it is
gonna take work to get people there and
it is going to require marketing effort
so tip 1 as I said I would opt for the
panel panelists approach make sure you
get the panelists to share with their
network that their comment on the
webinar so if you're smart and you get
people that have a good brand already in
your industry in your market then
hopefully
we'll and do some of the hard work for
you when these people shout about it to
their networks because hopefully people
in their network would like to see or
hear or see what they have to say if
they've got a good brand and are
respected in their market so that's the
first thing make sure you get the people
on the webinar to shout about it to
their networks so you're not just
relying on your own network I've
definitely found that sort of obviously
on I said about the two-week runway yes
you can get people to sign up two weeks
before the webinar but what I've
personally found if you're going to give
this some real marketing effort like put
put time aside make sure it's probably
within the 48 hours of the webinar I've
definitely found that sort of doing it a
day before and on the day you get an
influx of people signing up on the day
and also sort of a day before is also a
good time to to shout about it
so I would say that if you're going to
put all your eggs into one basket all
your eggs into a particular time period
to promote it and give yourself the best
possible chance of getting as many
people there I would do it in that 48
hour window and then yeah in terms of
marketing Gary what what I would do is
bring to life the conversations you're
likely to discuss on the webinar so
obviously you're going to do the typical
post of hosting this webinar got
such-and-such sign up below those types
of posts which is basically saying sign
up for my webinar but what I found what
I found to be really effective and is to
talk about and discuss and communicate
with your content the types of things
you're gonna talk about on the webinar
and then say and we're gonna be doing a
webinar in this sign up below and I've
gone example in a sec so not just sort
of saying and sharing content which is
sign up for my webinar like using your
content to say and communicate like why
you're putting it on the things we're
going to be talking about and hey by the
way we actually be doing a webinar on
this if you want to join and then last
but not least guys get on the phone ask
people message be proactive email your
database segment of your database like
you have to be proactive so yes you need
to market it yes you need to create some
content to make people aware of it but
don't underestimate like how impactful
it will be for you to call people and
say have you checked have you seen that
within a webinar and likewise messaging
I've had to do a lot of that I've had to
do the legwork and for those of you that
have been to a few of mine you
definitely would have got at least two
free messages so I'm practicing what I
preach here and it will create project
you have to be proactive as well so that
that's my sort of advice on the
promotion Chris hottyz is there an ideal
time to hold a webinar yep I've got that
in a sec with the host speaking Liz with
the host speaking how can I enable him
to share his screen to deliver his
presentation we are having a practice
run on Monday yeah Liz that that's a
really simple resume function don't
worry about that so that's great that
you did a practice run so yours
you'll speaker will be able to share
share their screen that that's no
problem don't be worrying about that
Chris I've got a slide and all the
things that you've asked in a second so
this is what I mean by that guys so
obviously you can as I said and I've
repeated myself but you're going to have
the hey guys
hosting the webinar signup but this is
what I found to be really affected where
I've got a lot of signups from so this
is just a post I did about personal
branding and guess what I'm doing a
webinar on personal branding so he said
the media jumping around and saying hey
guys I'm doing a webinar on personal
branding like sign up I've gone are
these your challenges this what you're
thinking about these you're forced
towards personal branding if so we're
gonna be discussing it on this webinar
sign up below so that that's just a bit
more a smarter way to promote the
webinar without just saying sign up
basically and I've found that to be
really effective and then the next part
guys that I wanted to communicate to all
of you is make sure that if you do do
this which I'd like to think hopefully
quite a few of you will take action like
make sure you squeeze as much juice out
of your efforts and what I mean by that
is if you're putting in the work getting
people to sign up you're doing it make
sure that you maximize the time and
effort that you put into it and that's
more of the afters like make sure the
you use the webinar to your advantage
after so make sure it's recorded so you
can upload it to YouTube after or with
with some platforms and more expensive
ones what you can do is I can then put
this recording on the landing page that
all have you registered for and for you
to watch the replay you have to then
give my you have you have to sign up and
input your email we should see another
way to gather leads so just make sure
that one you definitely record the
webinar because there's going to be some
good content in there or at least you're
using it after and then also make sure
that you're creating and sharing content
like extracted from that webinar so you
should easily be able to produce free or
four posts that sort of have come from
the webinar you bring to life the
conversations and discussions that you
had so just make sure you squeeze the
juice out of the efforts you put into
this it's important you want to maximize
the time and effort you put into this
and the marketing and the content you
can get out of the webinar after is also
really useful and and make sure that you
have that in mind so just an example
this is a post that I did I hosted a
live podcast with Tony Bates and Neil
Carberry see over the re-see and as you
can see reading that I just bring to
life one of the things that we discussed
which was about furlough which was about
can you create content or not and then
I've said look if you want to hear news
and take an advice and their skits
online minutes and watch the replay
right so make sure that we're squeezing
the juice out of the efforts and time
you're putting into this webinar and
doing this webinar and this is also a
good+ of doing a webinar is that there
will be plenty of opportunity to bring
to life the discussion points the
conversations in content afterwards that
would obviously be really useful to all
of you it was annoying
so as con and good question last week I
signed up to a webinar I got for
checking emails prices event it was
annoying enough for me to cancel my
attendance how much would you recommend
in touch with your audience prior to the
webinar yeah good question
so what setup has
automatic with this platform which I
think is a perfect amount and what I'd
probably recommend as is I would send
one email a day before the event and
basically and you would have got and why
you and I got them because you signed up
late but everyone that attended would
have got these so one day before the
event
hey as it's me just wanted to let you
know that the webinars in 24 hours time
this is what gonna be discussing this is
the link to join don't forget it and
really looking forward to seeing you
there so what 24 hours before and then
the other one that I send out is 30
minutes before so I think 2 is a good
amount of touch point so one the day
before just rely on people hire you I've
got that in my diary I forgot about that
and then also the like on the day five
minutes before hey airs got this webinar
in a sec real looking forward to seeing
you there so I reckon two touch points
is enough and hopefully that won't annoy
too many people but I agree for checking
emails is way too much I think that's
way I've reckon it like what what yeah
what is the point than that so that
would be my advice to that as hope that
helps so useful information I have used
and looked at so again what I'm gonna do
is just send you the links here guys so
just to save you the hassle so these are
just links but there's just really
useful information to look at one of
them was in 2017 but I just fingers
still this is a good sort of benchmark
so click those links open up those and
open up open up those tabs and this is
some good data points in there but these
are the key ones for me guys from loads
of data different sources people
definitely prepare preferred to attend
webinars and cheese day Wednesdays and
Thursdays they would be the days that I
go for and I've always done them on
Tuesdays or Wednesdays the first days
and 11 a.m. to 2 p.m.
best on to host there's loads of sources
on white on data backing that up
so I've done a couple of 11:00 a.m. and
I've done quite a few TV p.m. and
they've been really good times
and they've always got consistent and
number of attendees and people
registering so I would go for those
times your 11:00 a.m. or 2:00 p.m. and
so I think this is this is
importance that guys obviously there's
gonna be different sources out there but
78% of webinars have 50 people and under
50 people and under attend don't be hard
on yourself so you don't get too caught
up in our I've only got 15 people sign
up it's gonna be [ __ ] blah blah blah
like remember thinking of all the
webinars that have been done right now
on average 78 percent fit like 50 people
or under attend so don't be too hard on
yourself if you've got 12 13 14 15
people that head like remember they're
real human beings and that is still
useful even if it's three people ten
people obviously you want more people
there and I get it but don't I think
that's really interesting to start this
is another really interesting one as
well 78% of webinars used live Q&A make
sure you give the people what they want
I think that again come back to my point
of making people engaged and interact
and want to interact like make sure
there's always a segment to do Q&A like
I think especially when you're doing a
panel like I think that's what people
want person and what people get a lot of
value out of and and then look this is
another important one different sources
say between 35 to 45 percent is the
average attendance of webinars so just
think of that when you get your numbers
of the amount of people that register
our work to the worst case scenario
$0.35 that people are going to attend
and that'll give you a real idea and now
me personally I guess it definitely
helps with obviously I've built up a
brand over a long period of time and the
network and these types of things so
I've I've been getting anywhere between
70 to 75 percent attendance rate that's
just me personally but I think sort of
expecting 45 50 percent plus it is
probably pretty is pretty safe and I
think that normally will happen I think
that's what I've been surprised
obviously people put in their email and
you do get quite a good good commitment
right out of people so and yeah that
they're the sort of numbers that I'd
look at and be committee Jurgen
klippstein how do you develop and plan
your webinar good question so I'm gonna
okay so I'm going on to questions now
guys so just last 15 minutes just hit me
with questions I'm gonna give these a go
right so
so mark Thomas I'd like to think I've
answered your question on how to get
people to attend your webinar so I've
covered that so I'm gonna answer Jurgen
your question how do you develop and
plan your webinar great point so I will
be honest with you I don't do a whole
lot of planning but I think that's
because of the podcast that I've done
for over two years now I do have a
confident I'm confident in my own
ability of asking questions for silly
Technic conversations and and doing that
so if I was in your shoes and you may
not have that I would say and my best
advice would be to over prepare so I
would yoga and I would definitely get a
panel and the plan and what I would
think about would be the first 10 15
minutes I would I would know the
questions I'm gonna ask so the first 10
15 minutes of that webinar is going to
be setting the scene sort of getting
people a bit comfortable just having a
bit of an open conversation but what I
would do Guillen is I would have my
first free questions that I'm gonna ask
the panel written down and there the
question I want to ask so I've got that
blanket of I know what questions I'm
gonna ask and then what I would then
plan for is 30 minutes to 40 minutes of
questions and answers and just having a
conversation so my plan would be back to
the point of if I was you know she's
yoga and I would make sure that you're
getting people to submit questions so
what I would do my plan would be right
so I'm gonna get all the questions up
that most popular on and look at the
ones that I want to ask and we'll
maneuver the conversation and I've got
these Bank of questions that I can rely
on as we sort of having this
conversation so that would be my plan
and then the last 10-15 minutes would be
live Q&A but that's how I would do it
yoga and so I hope that helps but it
would be to over prepare so have
questions you're definitely not ask have
questions that you can lean on to ask
that being caught by the audience and
then hopefully by the end there'll be
some good opportunity to do some Q&A so
I hope that helps
juergen did the okay cool my so if you
have any questions advises let me know
Afghan what was the best webinar you
have held and why oh that's a good
question I'll go I'll go from feedback
and the most attended one which was the
personal branding one so why what why
was that why was that the best and why
so I think one right now a lot of
recruiters are thinking about building
their brand or it's become even more
important or it's become more higher on
the priority list with what's going on
so I think what what makes a webinar
more better is if it's on a topic and a
theme that is being fought about and a
lot of people are thinking about so I
think that's the first thing is if
you're if you're talking about a topic
and theme that will resonate with people
that's gonna give you the best possible
chance have been at a great webinar and
for it to be really useful and valuable
for people is if you're talking about
topic that a lot of people are thinking
about so that definitely helped with
that and then I think why was was just
that is because I was talking about
talking that people found useful I think
that's for me that should be the
objective I think the objective should
be with your webinar to provide value
make it useful informative and what's
going to really help that is if you're
answering people's questions and you're
helping and you're doing on topics that
people deem important right now so that
that's what I probably say Afghan so I
hope that helps and Chris have you heard
of a platform called ECAM if so what
your focus on the streaming live through
it Chris I have not I'm sorry
so I guess I I so I haven't done
streaming live or LinkedIn live or
anything like that but if I'm honest I
don't know I I do quite like the webinar
piece I think obviously live live work
and you can do YouTube live and all
these types of things
but I don't know I think the sort of
interactiveness of a webinar the Q&A the
function of using right now it's just a
bit more slick than the live options in
my opinion but I haven't used D cam and
I haven't got an opinion so apologies
would you suggest setting up as a
webinar yeah I would do a webinar that
that would be my that would be my choice
kress personally I think it will be a
lot easier to manage the engagement
people interacting and it's just a bit
more bit more slick I think that that's
what I would opt for and then maybe go
from there
sorry for pronounce this wrong but bin
iam BER he do you transfer the dialogue
of your webinar to your podcast could it
be useful yeah I I did that's exactly
what I did again thinking about
squeezing as much juice out of you
taking the time to do a webinar how you
can use it after obviously with me
recording this I'm gonna get a video
after that I can put up two I can put up
to YouTube and also what you can do
I'm pretty sure you can do it on any
laptop but what you can do really easily
is when you then get the video file
which I can download after this you can
then right-click the video and then put
encode encode to audio file and then you
get just the audio or any file and then
I upload that has a podcast so yeah
definitely Binion you can use the audio
of this for podcast and I think what's
really important there Binyam is if
you're going to use it as a podcast
audio is that for someone listening
what's really important if they're not
getting the visuals is that they get the
context so I think it's really important
to save people's name and ask and repeat
the question that was asked because if I
if I was just answering your questions
right now without saying what the
question was if I was to listen back
it's going to be pretty confusing so I
think that's just important to have in
mind and that's what I've definitely
made sure that I do Afghan do you think
subtitles are good to include in the
webinar I don't think so I don't know
and let on this
you you can't speak very clearly I don't
even know how you do that ever I have no
idea so I asked Anne I think I finger
overthinking it like don't worry about
subtitles maybe after when you share
some video snippets from it or whatever
but right now you don't need subtitles
I'm like definitely not be a Lauren
that's interesting you say that that's
my opinion like whenever I've gone on
LinkedIn live it's just weird like I
don't know like when you're engaging
it's a lot of comment and it's I don't
know I haven't actually done one but I
feel like it's not really an it's not
that it's not as interactive and it's
not as easy to interact them when you're
delivering it to keep an eye on the
comments and stuff of that all right
yeah so I think needs a sort of a bit
better
Ian how do you set up the podcast
channel to app on Google Play bit of a
different question on webinars but Ian
if you're if you're sort of further down
the road on the podcast run basically
you need to upload your audio to a
podcast hosting platform so basically
Google buzzsprout pod Beam or anchor or
captivate Google those and they will all
do the job for you and get that side and
Liz never what's the difference between
the live webinar and a live podcast
there isn't it's just it's just calling
it that there just isn't the reason why
I've gone for the reason why I've called
some of my webinars a lot of podcasts
webinars because it's attached to the
podcast and it's yeah it's a it's it's a
live podcast really but it's also a
webinar so there's no difference it's
the same thing it's completely same
thing it's a live in the moment right
now
I'm in my room right now we're at 11:52
a.m. you're engaging with me you're on
this webinar you're with me and on this
on this platform so it's live if it's a
book light if you call it a webinar or a
podcast webinar you're only gonna call
it a podcast webinar if it's if you're
attaching it to your podcast and your
dinner as a podcast episode there's no
difference it's the exact same thing and
Kress pretty sure you've been posted by
numerous when you started what kind of
numbers we get an attending maybe more
so on the podcast other things I don't
know you said you've only just started
webinars
yeah Crisler on the podcast been doing
it for turn two and years and like a
month or so and two months yeah I was
getting like 30 40 50 listens on the
podcast early on so that can give you a
bit of an idea it will take time and it
will build momentum but honestly guys
like don't underestimate the amount of
people that will want to find out how
people are getting on right now there
they've got really used to going on
video calls which this is a bit similar
to so what like I think when I've spoken
to clients that have sort of taken
action on a webinar idea they've been
really surprised the amount of people
that did attend or at least registered
and I think a big part of that right now
is people have become really accustomed
and and used to jumping on video people
probably attended more webinars than
they ever have before in this period and
also and I think hopefully the topic and
the theme that you talked about is going
to be something that more than one
person is thinking about so there's a
really good chance Chris that you'd be
surprised at the amount of people that
attend and want to get involved but to
answer your question yeah it did take
time and podcast listeners getting 30 40
50 listens per episode a month and to
give you an idea but definitely don't
underestimate the amount of people that
would be willing to attend a webinar and
I think you'll be pleasantly surprised
yep Liz that's definitely a case okay
cool
right so as we come to the end here so
if there's Joe Stacy what is the best
way to structure than buying a fix
question so just a quick one on the Joe
Stacy question which was quite similar
people saying how would you do that blah
blah blah
so for me I think it just got my advice
to all of you is definitely did of a
panel I think that would be I think that
would be the most beneficial and best
way to do it and so my advice would be
to structure the sort of first 10-15
minutes oh no the question is going to
ask and then sort of have an open
flowing conversation freeze
but have questions that you cannot
answer and do it that way and then make
sure you've got a bit of a segment like
this where people can interact ask their
questions and do it that way I think
that's a pretty solid stretch sure and
that's what I've been doing first 10-15
minutes these are going to be the first
three questions that one ask you guys
and this is what to expect and and then
I've got questions from the audience and
that's what I would do
Chris uploading the webinars to a
podcast is its simple top load and what
platform do you record your pod on we
use anchor currently okay so yeah if you
use an anchor and then no stress you
uploaded to that so basically what
you'll need to do Chris is yeah so
really simply that you're gonna get a
video from this you'll then download the
video you'll then be able to rip out the
audio only file from the video and then
you'll be able to do like you have been
doing with your other podcast episodes
just upload the audio file to anchor and
that will do the trick mate so that it's
really easy don't don't be too stressed
about it you'll work it out if not
Google will help you out on YouTube but
it's it's super easy okay so 11:56 if
there's if any of you are thinking I
really want to ask this question get it
in now before I close this out but make
sure make sure you've got those links
guys Oh actually we know what I'll send
it in an email as well I'll send it in
the follow-up email with the replay I'll
send it with the links that I've sent
you today on the public chat thing I
will I'll send it in an email so you can
all have access to that but look guys I
hope you enjoyed that got use out of it
don't you know you done that so look if
you if you guys are gonna take action
get your first webinar done and you're
like oh my god I wish I had Haitians
help right now just just drop me a
message I'm happy to help but honestly
guys parting words would be don't get
too bogged down with the tech like you
zoom take action do it get it in the
diary say openly to the public that
you're gonna host one so you have
neither option but to do it take action
do your first one and then learn from it
and go from there but yeah guys take
action and hope you enjoyed it and look
keep going we're gonna get through this
together and I hope you'll enjoy the
rest of your week and weekend it's meant
to be sunny so I am super excited but
I'm gonna end this webinar now so thank
you guys for joining me really
appreciate it and if you need help with
anything just drop me a mess